[Music]  throughout my life  the ten rings gave our family power  if you wanted them to be yours one day  you have to show me you are strong  enough to carry them  john you are a product of all who came  before you  the legacy of your family  you are your mother and whether you like  it or not  you are also your father  i told my men  they wouldn't be able to kill you if  they tried  glad i was  right he's just a criminal  who murders people  be careful how you speak to me boys  i thought i could change my name  start a new life  but i could never  escape his shadow  my son  you can't run from your past  [Applause]  is this what you wanted  you got  this thank you